WE ITICS," SUNDAY,Y
UKRAINE WHERE VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
USINING BASE  THE
ANDLI                     TH.
DESTROYED.
NO FOOD AS RUSSIANS BOMBAR
THEM.
THIS WOMARATED FM HER SBANAND C
LEE,P.
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL CY.DEST
THERE IS NYMPE.LION PEOPLE STIL.
EVER LESS AND LESS F
>> MEANWHILE, CLOSING IN
ON
FROM THEITCENTRE, AND U.S.
BE WILLING TO
USE CHEMALNS TO THINIAN
ZELENSKYY IS WORRIED, TOO, AND
AGAIN CALLED OE WEST TMORE MILI
ERATING TOS AND
ND SITE OFR COUNTRY.INIANS AND
SIGNIFICANT AT.N 30 MISSILECOMIU
YOU CAN IMAGINE, THE SON TREMEL.
EVENC ROADS LEADING TO
BEE. Y L
THERE  MENN CATALKING TO THEM.
TH SP WITH
MEL N, I REPEAT THAT
MOHAUNIT'SEVASTATEAL
IFIED FAMILIES WHO, OF, HEARD TN
HUY CONSEQUENCES.SO
BASE, AGAIN, E
HE AWAY,
COIDE THE TA OPEWH MEETSALLIES
WHERE IN T PAST JUST A FEWNT AU
AND UKRANG, HELD BETWE
ISS ITS BASE THAT OPS UP
S ES AND
W .
ANS AS TPRE MILITARY SUPPORT,
REMEMBER, JUSTRDAY WE
HEARD $200 MILLION IN DIGGS
GGS  -- EFENSE SPENDING MADE
TOUCATION,OR
IL FN
THE FR.
HOW DOES THA IE
HOW DOANS E ER FORCES SAIDANONYS
RUSSIAN FORCESER EGITIMTARGTHISP
REALLY, TO THE UAN I FEFR N
OFTCHING FROM THE
EAST TO THE WEST OF THE COUNTRY.
ARMY GENERAL KIMMITT.SE COUNTR U
GENERAL KIMMITT THAT ATTK A COUP
PR
CLEARLY ETTO
>>HIRILYAINIANUKRAINIANS IN THOU
W HETONGE ATTACKED IE NORTH, E
SEND ACAIOHEANT CUT OFF THE SUPA
THE. >> W RH TO
SE ALCULATION.O ONEFO
T FALLS INTO OHES WITH
PRESIDENO THEN?
>>S RED LINE.
WACLOSELY.THAT CONVODISBURSED,
ANALYSTS SAY THEE BRACIN
O BE UNDER HEAVY
AND BRACING FOR  THININNS SO ?Y
G TO C INK COMPLETELY MIST
REMAINS, HE
DIDN IT.NOW 'RG CK TO THE
SLMETHODICALLY SSHV BEFORE THEY
>> IDEINE SUCHDESPERATE N IN TH
CITY POTENTIALLY THAT ITTHE GOVU
T PUTIN'S, U
OSOPHY.E BEENALBOFOR NUCLEAR WEN
HORRI, KLY?NSU INCHANCES WE AR
RSRUIANE DOESN'T HAVSENSE THAT
THERS ERCONVENTIONAL WAR AND.E S
BUT DON'T SEEE -TI AN
CONSEQUENCES OG FROMNVENTIONAL L
NUCLEAON
THISI THINK
WE NEE BARED F THAT.
>>MEANI THINK THAT THAS
JU FT WOULR THE ME MORE KET
VON UKRAINE.
HE
RIGHT?CLR T WOULD BE R I.
THEIS
ABPRWORLD WAR III?HALYBEGUN?
>> I DON'T THINKO.I THINK WORLD
CO BETWEEN NATO
NOELD
INTO THEA TREATY OBLIG
FE THE SAYS,
>> PRESIDENT BBC , AS WEER WITH
INTERV RUSSI
S IN UKRAINETHAT IS ANGER"TOU TS
IO
D THAT SENTEDT CROSS IT
VEEMICALACT >>E WE PREPARED IUU
ECONOMICT HAVELE LOTNT
I KNOW D SANGER WILL WITH UTBEE
WILL BE A IFUSNS. T TOUT DEBATE
THIS WEEK INO TH
THMS TO HAVE BEE
OFF THE TABLE.
WHORE MILITARILYUNITED STAD O
GET, HELP GIVE UAI HAND>> THE M
THIS WAR IY TAKEN A
ON THERY O
E HAVE TO CONTINUEO DO
HAT TH HAVE.THEY HNO MAG
SHORT  BRINGING IN PATRIOT  AND
SYSTEM NOT TRAINEDN
HAVEHET
REQUIRES NATTROOPS IN OPERATE >
AGREE WIN NOT
ME THERE'S A PRETLL.
TOUGH DENST
CKLY'S,  OTHE ION IS NOT BTHEULK